ihr seht ja sensationell
aus hallo
Katrin SAR Meike Julia kommt her rein
dan hier ist Bescherung wir haben es
richtig schön uns schön
gemacht da auf das Sofa auf ich hoffe
ihr passt da alle
aber wie ist die
Lage dieage ja ja klar alles super wir
waren ja gerade bei Stefan Rab bei
Schlag den Rab wir haben es richtig
gerockt gerade das war so geil was ist
das für ein
Gefühl ja h das für ein Gefühl ja das
ist endlich mal wieder ein tolles Gefühl
auf der Bühne stehen zu können und das
den Leuten zu zeigen wie gut wir
eigentlich sind und wie gut wir
performen können und ja das ist ein
super tolles Gefühl wieso endlich mal
das habt ihr doch jetzt wochenlang
gemacht ja natürlich in den Live shuss
aber jetzt in der Zeit hatten wir sehr
viel Promotour und haben unsere Single
vorgestellt und unser Album und da war
nicht so viel mit Auftritten also da
muss man sich echt auf die Promotour
konzentrieren und die Single gut
darstellen genau so in unserer
Konstellation jetzt als laviv so in der
Öffentlichkeit noch gar nicht so richtig
präsentieren können jetzt sind wir hier
das ist unsere neue Single und wir sind
total cool und gut drauf und deswegen ja
war also ein voller Erfolg ja super sehr
schön
weil das hab wir haben das ja so im
Vorfeld mitbekommen mit den Dreien habe
ich ja schon gesprochen Einzelgespräch
zweier Gespräch Dreier Gespräch
eigentlich hat sich jede von euch eine
andere Band gewünscht ja wie kommt er
jetzt damit zurecht sehr gut also ja am
Anfang hätte sich keiner so vorstellen
können von uns in dieser
bandkonstellation dann endgütlich laviv
zu werden ja man muss damit umgehen
natürlich
und ich muss ehrlich sagen dass es sehr
gut läuft dass wir uns sehr gut
verstehen was ich auch am Anfang nicht
gedacht hätte dass es so klappen würde
aber ja es ist einfach echt lustig mit
den Mädels ja es ist halt irgendwie
witziger als man je sich hätte er
träumen können also ich habe ich habe
selber auch nicht mit dieser
Konstellation gerechnet und jetzt lernt
man sich halt noch mal komplett neu
kennen man hat sich halt bei Popstars
kennengelernt aber klar B sich bei 25
Mädels irgendwie Grüppchen und ja jetzt
wo man wirklich eine von laviv ist dann
lernt man sich noch mal als LAV Mädchen
kennen irgendwie das ist noch mal
komplett was neues so z.B ich hatte mit
relativ wenig in der popszeit zu tun
dafür halt viel mehr mit Katrin und Meik
und ich lachen jetzt irgendwie ungefähr
geschätzte 100000 mal am Tag das ist
echt das ist echt total Wahnsinn und das
ist es ist wirklich cool ich hätte damit
niemals gerechnet war das den nicht
jedes Mal so dass ihr gedacht habt ach
jetzt kommt
die weil ihr wolltet ja nicht ihr habt
ja vorher immer gesagt ne eigentlich
hätten wir gerne die oder eigentlich die
das ist ja ganz normal also du hast ja
z.B bei mir war ja so ich habe die ganze
Zeit gesagt ich möchte jonon war meine
Bezugsperson in der Zeit und ich kann es
ist eine Castingshow immer noch ist kein
Wunschkonzert und dafür sind wir
eigentlich alle professionell genug und
haben uns auch alle in der Zeit nicht
gehasst wir hatten einfach nur unsere
Bezugspersonen und in der Konstellation
ist jetzt genauso jetzt haben wir uns
alle vier und wir verstehen uns super
also da gibt's auch jetzt nichts mehr
dran zu rütteln oder jetzt irgendwie
noch drüber nachzudenken oh jetzt hätte
ich gerne die Esra oder die jonja oder
dieba gehabt wir sind jetzt wir und das
ist genauso perfekt wie wir sind und
trauert er dem nicht nach die habt ihr
jetzt hinter euch lassen die stehen da
winken euch vielleicht noch hier jettet
los natürlich ist es ein bisschen
ungewohnt jetzt am Anfang ich meine wir
waren über ein ziemlich langen Zeitraum
alle immer unter einem Dach da fehlt
natürlich was in der ersten Zeit ne aber
wir haben uns jetzt so dran gewöhnt dass
wirur noch zu vier sind und wir haben
super viel Spaß also vor allen Dingen
haben wir auch so viel zu tun also da
kann man gar nicht so oft an die anderen
Mädels denken oder irgendwie ja den
Gedanken daran verschwenden mit denen
jetzt irgendwie was zu unternehmen oder
sonst was also es ist wirklich
viel zu tun Mädels
ne und ich also mir bei mir persönlich
ist es so es ist so ein kleiner break in
der Zeit passiert zwischen Finalshow
Popstars und laviv Promotour und ich
finde wir haben jetzt unseren Job als
laviv Mädels und wir sind glücklich
damit und natürlich wir haben alle
Mädels lieb gehabt die irgendwie noch
dabei waren aber man sollte da das eine
gute Balance zwischen halten können
irgendwie zwischen laviv und den
Popstars Mädels weil ich meine Popstars
hat uns dahingebracht wo wir jetzt sind
aber Popstars und laviv ist jetzt noch
mal ein Break zwischen okay aber es gibt
noch ein Punkt ihr seid ja
unterschiedlicher wie man nicht sein
also geil also wenn man wenn man jetzt
wenn man jetzt ein Caster wäre und sagt
hier das ist laviv da würde sagen das
kannst du nicht machen die Pass nicht
zusammen das geht nicht was was sagt er
dazu ja man sagt ja bekanntlicherweise
Gegensätze zieht sich ziehen sich
an und
das schon witzig so wie es ist also es
ist ganz gut so ich meine ich finde es
macht uns auch ein bisschen
interessanter ich meine jeder hat so
seine kleine Rolle und trotzdem sind wir
ein Paket okay und wenn wir alle gleich
werden wär so total langweilig oder
warte mal jetzt noch kin die sieh gen a
wie die andere do scheiße
oder
Hall wir sind ja auf Internetportal
YouTube und sonst wo ja auch so da
gibt's ja ganz viele Leute die nach oben
gekommen sind und die wären nie
erfolgreich gewesen wenn da ein
professionelles pass auf
sch die wären nie erfolgreich gewesen
wenn dann professionelles Management
hintergesteckt habt seid ihr vielleicht
auch sowas wie die Stars einer neuen
Generation die sich eben durch Voting
durch ähäh die Meinung äh äh von der
Mehrheit nach oben äh äh kommt und
vielleicht dadurch eine bessere Chance
hat auf Dauer ich glaube schon dass wir
dieses Jahr auf jeden Fall
eine ganz andere Tür noch mal geöffnet
haben jeder auf seine Art und Weise ich
meine Popstars gibt's ja nicht zum
ersten Mal und alle haben da ihre ja
keine Ahnung guten oder auch schlechten
Meinungen dazu aber ich denke mal dass
durch uns dadurch dass die Zuschauer uns
gewählt haben die Leute jetzt sich
endlich mal denken ja dieses Jahr war
popst richtig toll sind genau die in die
Band gekommen die es verdient haben für
die am meisten angerufen wurde und
deswegen denke ich mal dass es schon
noch mal was anderes ist wobei es wird
heftig diskutiert viele sagen die sollte
eigentlich also das ist ja genau im
Publikum ist ja genauso dass die alle
sagen die sollte eigentlich B und die
und na ja das ist wie bei irgendwelchen
Wahlen auch da möchte der eine den einen
Bürgermeister und der andere den anderen
dann wird der eine gewählt der
vielleicht die Hälfte nicht mag und sie
müssen trotzdem alle zufrieden sein und
sagen dann hinter ach guck mal der ist
doch gar nicht so schlecht und ich denke
mal so wird es bei uns auch sein gut wir
war die
koalitionsverhandlung also ihr habt euch
geeinigt ja kein großer
Koalitionsvertrag alles prima alles
super super perfekt pass auf jetzt haben
wir ich habe sie jetzt gerade noch nicht
in der Hand die neue
CD warte mal warte mal warte mal danke
danke also da habe ich jetzt kurz mal
reingehört weil das ist ja auch wieder
ganz
frisch das ist ja gar nicht
schlechton Anfang an
gesagt hab das den so
hingekriegt das muss ja ihr müsst ja
alles schon eingesungen haben als als
wäend der Produktion sonst wäre das ja
gar nicht möglich gewesen oder nimmst es
jetzt oder derer sagt jetzt was ja ich
sag jetzt dann halt was
Mensch ja also das mit dem Album ist es
wurde aufgenommen als wir noch zu Zeh
waren also die letzten zehn Kandidaten
haben alle das Album eingesungen jeder
hat den Song jeden Titel komplett
durchgesungen und letztendlich wurden
halt die stimmen dann wendet die dann
jetzt hier sitzen nein weil es mich oft
sind ja Casting CDs
wirklich hören sich gerade von also das
Hauptproblem in der Musikbranche sind ja
die Songs
es gibt ganz viele Alben die klingen
zwar super aber es sind keine Songs
drauf und hier das ist so ein Album da
sind echt also ich habe mir mal überlegt
so fünf könnte ich mir den Charts
vorstellen und das ist ja für für ein
Casting Album schon außergewöhnlich ja
das ist ja da freuen wir uns auch drüber
als wir die Songs gehört haben weil es
erstmal so okay
toll aber dann das sind einfach so viele
Ohrwürmer und die Lieder machen auch so
viel Spaß ja wir haben schon von Anfang
an gesagt dass unser Album toll ist also
ne was soll man dazu noch mehr sagen ist
halt schön zu hören dass also auch viele
Fans bestätigen uns irgendwie das was
wir in den letzten Monaten wofür wir
hart gearbeitet haben und es ist halt
schön zu hören dass Leuten unser Album
gefällt weil wir selber sehen jetzt das
Endprodukt wie geil es geworden ist auch
wenn uns die Demo vielleicht anfangs
nicht so gefallen hat aber wir haben was
geiles dusus gezaubert und ich finde das
ist gut so wieso wer hat denn die Demo
euch vorgesungen hat wir mussen ganz
schnell lernen wir haben dann z D Tage
vorher den Text bekommen die Melodie und
dann so ungefähr wie man sich das
vorgestellt hat wir hten ja auch vocal
coach der uns da betreut hat natürlich
das Wahnsinn in welchem Tempo jetzt das
Hauptproblem bei allen Casting Bands ist
ja den dauerhaften Erfolg zu sichern wie
wollt ihr das
machen
ja das ist schon alleine die Tatsache
dass wir was komplett neues sind da
haben wir es denke ich mal schon
bisschen einfacher und ja wir haben uns
geschworen dass wir zusammenhalten
werden egal was passiert und dass wir
alles versuchen werden um lange
durchzuhalten um einfach an die Spitze
der Charts zu kommen und ja ich glaube
das wird dann so in Zukunft unser Rezept
sein Gott wie wie habt ihr euch das
geschworen habt ihr da abends
blutsbruderschafteschlossen od getrunken
welche Getränke waren dabei Robby Bubble
was ist Robby Bubble
Kind
okay ja war der Schwur nein also wir
haben uns als ich dann zuletzt
reingewählt
wurde haben wir noch mal ganz kurz im
Auto ich glaube das war wo sind wir
hingefahren zum Stefan Rab hab noch mal
gesagt so Mädels das das ist jetzt laviv
und wir schwören uns hier mit immer
ehrlich zueinander zu sein hart zu
arbeiten damit es auch wirklich was wird
und ja und einfach durchzuhalten und das
war das war glaube ich da der Moment
Moment können Frauen ehrlich sein
natürlich das fragt Mann also man muss
ja auch dazu sagen eigentlich das beste
Rezept gegen gegen sowas ist erstmal
dass wir nie vergessen dass sie wir zum
ksting gekommen sind weil wir Musikerin
sind weil wir Sängerinnen sind die für
irgendw wasas Leben und bei uns ist es
halt die Musik und sich wegen
irgendwelchen blöden Streitigkeiten da
irgendwie zu trennen wie keine Ahnung du
hast jetzt die gleiche ha fararbe wie
ich das passt ja jetzt nicht ich gehe
jetzt tschüss sowas gibt's bei uns nicht
und egal was passiert wir werden immer
reden auch wenn es mal hart ist und
Michael nicht zufrieden ist oder Julia
nicht zufrieden ist mit dem was ich
gerade zu dir sagt müssen wir trotzdem
immer versuchen professionell zu
arbeiten
ja dann muss ich ehrlich sagen ich
wünsche euch dabei echt viel Erfolg und
drück euch die Daumen weil eigentlich
das Album ist sensationell äh jetzt
müsst das nur richtig an Mann bringen
danke schön ja also auch noch mal Danke
dass wir so oft bei euch eingeladen
wurden es war sehr schön dass ihr uns so
mit verfolgt habt und immer wieder gerne
wir sind gerne bereit ich fand spannend
das mal so mitzubekommen weil das
wirklich diese
Geschichte das ist also wirklich schon
lustig gewesen be näch mal kannst du
fragen wo wollt ihr als nächstes hin W
möch als nächstes
Treffen sind wir ja dann dabei gucken
wir mal danke auf jeden Fall danke
schön